a Texas man discovered that a major
setback in life can force you to start
something new and even bring some
amazing results in this case the change
began with ice cream and a dog who
doesn't love that Omar via Franca
reports
it's delivery day for will Gibson and
his canine co-pilot together they
deliver homemade ice cream and sweet
greetings who wouldn't want to buy
something that tastes amazing and you
know that you're supporting someone
behind it the person behind it is a
former home theater salesman now ice
cream entrepreneur a career change
forced by a bicycle crash that left
Gibson in severe pain and unable to work
making ice cream at home started as a
hobby to keep him busy and evolved into
a business gorgeous now Gibson turns out
600 pints a week when you were in the
hospital did you think that there was
light at the end of this tunnel no no
ice cream rescued Gibson and his rescue
dog has become the name and face of his
company Sweet Pearl she showed up
abandoned on his doorstep while he was
recovering Pearl and I had each other
I'm probably going to be suffering to
some degree for the rest of my life but
all of this is worth it
and The Business of Second Chances
extends to Gibson's only employee
Valentin Granado recently released from
a five-year prison sentence for assault
to be given the opportunities that he's
given me is it's life-changing for me a
business changing lives one scoop at a
time white chocolate and churro coffee
it is my absolute favorite one
for CBS Saturday morning Omar via Franca
Garland Texas
now I'm tearing up I know sometimes all
you need is a second chance yeah and a
rescue pup there it is
sorry I had to do it ain't a dog voice
there's another one really good